im bewerbungsverfahren diskriminiert
werden wegen der rasse der ethnischen
herkunft des geschlechts der religion
oder auch der weltanschauung oder einer
behinderung des alters oder der
sexuellen identität das passiert leider
immer noch viel zu häufig der trans frau
sophie fluege.de hat wegen ihres trans
science einen job eben nicht bekommen
und die absage mit dieser begründung
sogar direkt als mailbox nachricht aufs
handy bekommen
frau
kurze sache sie waren bei uns beim
probearbeiten im wunden pflegezentrum
moers wir waren sehr zufrieden mit ihm
unser problem jetzt ist halt einfach nur
dass viele bewohner sich von ihnen nicht
fliegen lassen möchten wegen ihrer
neigung
das tut mir echt wirklich unheimlich
leid aber ich muss ihnen leider absagen
und wir müssen uns da wirklich jemand
anders entscheiden leider okay diese
absage bekommt so pflüger weil sie
transsexuell ist ein klarer fall von
diskriminierung und das sogar
festgehalten
mir diese spanne reicht schon noch zwei
mal anhören
musste dann auch man sollte man mir paar
tränen verdrücken weil es ist schon
krass wenn man zu hören bekommt man wird
nicht genommen war eigentlich sehr
zufrieden bin ein aber man wird nicht
genommen aufgrund seiner neigung sowie
ihr das auch wirklich gesagt hat so viel
pflege aus duisburg wollte eigentlich
hier im wohn und pflegezentrum moers als
pflegeassistentin anfangen hat probe
gearbeitet dann dieser absage hammer
eine kritik die sophie flüge nicht
nachvollziehen kann ich habe hier seit
eineinhalb jahren in der pflege und noch
nie haben sich irgendein bewohner
beschwert und war dann auch davon sehr
getroffen und will das jetzt einfach
publik machen das geht ja gar nicht
diskriminierend und ich habe so etwas
noch nie erlebt diese diskriminierung
lässt die 27 jährige nicht auf sich
sitzen und geht jetzt rechtlich gegen
die einrichtung vor ich bin mit meiner
haltung gerade dabei
die haben uns angebote gemacht
zu anfang wurde sogar die sprache
verneint dass es die gar nicht gäbe
das haben wir dann später bewiesen
und ja jetzt aktuell plant oder teams
bereitet meine anwälte eine klage vor
weil das was die uns geboten haben nicht
unseren vorstellungen entsprach und
genau das ist jetzt das weitere vorgehen
ein mutiger schritt und ein wichtiger
schritt hin zu einer
diskriminierungsfreien gesellschaft denn
gerade in der heutigen zeit sollte das
ja egal sein sollen hauptsache die
bewohner sind gut gepflegt und
da ist das eigentlich egal vor gericht
klagte sophie pflüger jetzt auf
schmerzensgeld aber noch viel wichtiger
ihre leidenschaft für den pflegeberuf
kann sie jetzt in einer neuen anstellung
einbringen
tja was dann und alles genau falsch
gelaufen ist und welche rechtlichen
möglichkeiten es gibt darüber besprechen
wir jetzt mit dem arbeitsrechtler arndt
kempkes schön morgen erkennen kasten rum
wie sieht dann aus wie sind jetzt die
erfolgsaussichten für freiflüge
also die erfolgsaussichten sind gut denn
wir haben ja gerade im beitrag gehört
auch bürger sagt ja es sollte keine
benachteiligung geben das gesetz geht
darüber deutlich hinaus es darf keine
benachteiligung eben aufgrund auch der
sexuellen identität und der neigung und
dergleichen da darf es keine
unterscheidung geben arbeitsrechtlich
und genau das ist im gesetzlich geregelt
wir haben die mailbox nachricht gehört
die frau pflüger vom heimleiter auf ihr
handy bekommen hat gegen welches recht
verstößt der heimleiter mit dieser
absage
also das besondere in diesem fall ist ja
dass der heimleiter ihr klar sagt sie
sind eigentlich die richtige wir würden
sie gerne einstellen und sie haben auch
die fachliche qualifikation aber eben
aufgrund dieses verstoßes gegen das
allgemeine gleichbehandlungsgesetz
paragraf eins das man eben das nicht
unterscheiden darf aufgrund der
sexuellen identität jemanden zu
benachteiligen und genau das wird er
hier ganz offensichtlich gemacht und
sogar durch diese aufnahme bewiesen
solche diskriminierungsfälle sind ja nun
leider keine einzelfälle zwischen 13
prozent und 30 prozent der trans
personen in der eu geben an eben wegen
ihres trank science diskriminiert zu
werden oder diskriminiert worden zu sein
nicht immer ist die absage aber auf band
wie geht man denn als betroffen haben
jetzt so was am besten im
also das ganz besondere ist dass das
gesetz so eine beweis erleichterung
vorsieht wenn also nur der anschein
besteht dass es ebenso eine
benachteiligung sein könnte also ein
verstoß gegen das agg das allgemeine
gleichbehandlungsgesetz
dann wandelt sich die beweislast dann
muss nämlich der arbeitgeber die
arbeitgeberin beweisen dass eben
benachteiligt wurde wenn man also einen
kleinen anhaltspunkt hat reicht das aus
und dann ist sozusagen der arbeit über
die arbeitgeberin in der beweislast
nachzuweisen dass alles in ordnung
gelaufen ist und das ist natürlich im
einzelfall schwierig also man kann sagen
die prozesse alle situationen für die
betroffenen ein verstoß nachzuweisen ist
eigentlich wenn so ein kleiner radar
eine indiz besteht eigentlich relativ
einfach auch wie viel schmerzensgeld
kann man denn in so einem fall klagen
das ist etwas offen es gibt noch nicht
so wahnsinnig viele urteile dazu aber es
gibt im gesetz sogar eine regelung die
sagt man kann bis zu drei monatsgehälter
ein schmerzensgeld bekommen wenn man
ohnehin nicht eingestellt worden wäre
also wenn man sozusagen nach dem gesetz
sagen würde du hättest sonst diesen job
nicht bekommen bis aber trotzdem
benachteiligt worden selbst an kriegt
man schon drei monatsgehälter bis zu
drei monatsgehälter schmerzensgeld aber
hier ist es ja noch viel krasser hier
wird ja ausdrücklich gesagt du hättest
den job sogar bekommen so dass diese
höchstgrenze die wir hier eingeblendet
sehen nämlich dreimonatsgeld gilt nicht
sondern das kann sogar noch wesentlich
mehr sein weil in diesem fall hätte die
betroffenen ja den job sogar bekommen
und kriegt ihn einfach nicht und dann
sind die schmerzensgeldansprüche
deutlich höhere ich persönlich würde
hier ohne weiteres sagen siebeneinhalb
1000 euro bis zu 10.000 euro das würde
ich persönlich
durchaus angemessen halten